I think I'm like the only committee member that's like just thrilled about macros and the preprocessor. Like I love macros. I'm confused on why we're not recording this on like April 1st. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 15 recorded on February 20th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today my co-host Bryce tries to convince me why macros are awesome. Yeah, so I want to talk about the C++ preprocessor i i think i'm like the only committee member that's like just thrilled about macros and the preprocessor like i love macros i i bryce low back i'm a member of the c plus plus committee and i am telling you right here and right now i love macros macros are great i mean let me put it to you this way let me make you the
我觉得我是委员会里唯一一个对宏和预处理器感到无比兴奋的成员。就像我热爱宏一样。我很纳闷为什么我们不把这期节目安排在4月1日录制呢。欢迎来到ADSP播客，我是康纳，今天是2021年2月20日录制的第15期节目。今天我的联合主持人布莱斯试图说服我为什么宏是那么棒。是的，我想聊聊C++预处理器。我觉得我是委员会里唯一一个对宏和预处理器感到无比兴奋的人，我是真的热爱宏。我是布莱斯·洛巴克，我是C++委员会的成员，我在这里郑重地向大家宣布，我热爱宏，宏太棒了。我的意思是，让我这样向你阐述，让我向你举个
case think of a language feature like a major language feature from the c++ 11 era every one of them at some point was prototyped in some like library only form and boost and it would not have been possible without macros see like macros are amazing they're so powerful they they let you do things that like they let you do syntax hacks that are just not possible uh uh in the regular language and even a hygienic macro facility like some of the ones that we're looking at having right now. Like some could argue that const eval functions, which const eval functions in C++, it's something that's similar to constexpr, but constexpr says this function may be evaluated at compile time as a constant expression. Const eval says this
例子。想想C++ 11时期的某个语言特性，比如某个重大语言特性，它们中的每一个在某个阶段都曾以仅限库的形式在Boost中被原型化过，如果没有宏，这是不可能实现的。看，宏是多么神奇，它们是如此强大，它们让你能够做到一些事情，比如让你做出常规语言中根本无法实现的语法黑客。甚至像我们现在正在研究的一些那种卫生宏机制也是如此。有些人可能会认为const eval函数——C++中的const eval函数类似于constexpr，但constexpr表示这个函数可能会在编译时作为常量表达式求值。而const eval表示这个
function must be evaluated at compile time. So it must be evaluated in the equivalent of being inlined fully at compile time. So it's a little bit stronger than constexpr, and it's an error if you use it in a way where it would need to be evaluated at runtime. But even that, it doesn't give you the same power of macros because macros are inherently textual. And so because they're textual, they let you do all sorts of hacks. Now, of course, as somebody who has had some involvement in modules in the past, I'll also tell you that macros are terrible. And the whole textual inclusion model for C++ is a large part of the compile time woes that we have. And while I agree with that, they do have their uses. I wanted to do this episode because recently one of the people in my team,
函数必须在编译时求值。所以它必须在完全等同于在编译时内联的情况下求值。因此它比constexpr更严格一点，如果你以需要在运行时求值的方式使用它，就会报错。但即便如此，它也无法给你提供宏所具备的那种威力，因为宏本质上是纯文本的。正因为它们是文本，所以它们能让你做出各种各样的黑客操作。当然，作为一个过去曾参与过模块（modules）工作的人，我也会告诉你宏其实很糟糕。而且C++整套文本包含模型正是我们面临的编译时长痛苦的大部分原因。虽然我同意这一点，但它们确实有其用处。我之所以想做这一期节目，是因为最近我团队里的一个人，
I needed them to create a new fancy macro abstraction for something, a portability layer around some new thing that we're putting into one of our compilers. And as he got started with it, I started teaching him some of the like dark arts of, of, uh, macro hacking and C plus plus. And, uh, and I introduced him to boost preprocessor. And just as I was doing that, I just remembered my love and passion for, um, uh, macro programming. Um, and I don't know why I love it so much. Because it's kind of horrendous. But I think that that's part of why.
我需要他为某个东西创建一个新的花哨的宏抽象，也就是在我们正投入编译器的新功能周围建立一个可移植性层。当他开始着手时，我开始教他一些C++中宏黑客技术的“黑魔法”，并且我向他介绍了Boost preprocessor。就在我这么做的时候，我突然想起了我对宏编程的热爱与激情。而且我不知道为什么我这么喜欢它。因为它其实挺可怕的。但我想这也是魅力的一部分。就好像是，哇，酷，你知道的，你绝对不会想到能在预处理器里做到这种事，但你真的可以。你知道预处理器是图灵完备的吗？我不知道这件事。不。是的，预处理器是图灵完备的吗？我不知道这件事。不。是的，它是图灵完备的。
That's part of the appeal. It's like, oh, cool. Like, you know, you would never think that you could do this thing in the preprocessor. But you can. Did you know that the preprocessor is Turing complete? I did not know that. No. Yeahrocessor is Turing complete? I did not know that. No. Yeah, it's Turing complete.
你听说过Boost preprocessor吗？我听说过，但不知道它是什么。我的意思是，我猜它和C++预处理器有关，就像用它来做一堆事情一样。它是一个预处理器库，所以Boost preprocessor是一个……我敢说它是预处理器编程中唯一的通用泛型库。而且我认为它绝对算得上是我最喜欢的Boost库。我对Boost Spirit永远有着一种特殊的喜爱，我在职业生涯的早期曾参与过它的开发。
Have you ever heard of Boost preprocessor? I've heard of it, but I don't know what it is. I mean, I assume it's adjacent to the C++ preprocessor, like doing a bunch of stuff with that. It is a prep-processor library so boost pre-processor is um a uh i i would argue it's like the only generic like general purpose library for pre-processor programming um and i think it's it's it's it's probably got to be my favorite Boost library. I will always have a special affinity for Boost Spirit, which I worked on very early in my career.
但Boost Preprocessor是我至今仍在使用的唯一一个Boost库。你可以用它做所有这些事情，这简直有点疯狂。首先，我们来谈谈数据类型。你可能从没想过预处理器数据类型的存在吧？没有。好吧。另外，在我们深入探讨之前，这会很有趣，因为你要在这里大力推销一番，因为我的职业生涯是从一家公司开始的，我不想用那个词。我不想用那个词。
But Boost Preprocessor is the one Boost library that I still use today. And it's a little bit crazy, all the stuff that you can do with it. First of all, let's talk about data types. You've probably never thought about preprocessor data types, right? No. Okay. Also, just before we get into this, this is going to be good because you have a real hard sell here because I started my career working for a company that I don't want to use the word. I don't want to use that word.
但我们只能说，他们严重依赖、我们的代码库严重依赖预处理器来支持我们软件系统中的不同模块。这导致了各种疯狂的情况，比如想象一下同一个函数，函数声明周围带有四种不同的预处理器上下文，比如参数列表。它们全都对齐了，所以你知道，模块A有10个可能函数参数或实参中的5个，模块B有6个。然后把它们全部对齐。它们甚至能做到让函数声明长达400个字符，带有6种不同的上下文。所以，我是见识过预处理器阴暗面的人。所以，（笑）祝你好运，布莱斯。祝你能让我对Boost preprocessor感到兴奋。
But let's just say that they heavily relied, our code base heavily relied on the preprocessor for different modules that our software system supported. And it led to just crazy things like picture the same function with like four different preprocessor contexts around the function declaration, like the parameter lists. And they're all lined up for so like, you know, module A has, you know, five of the 10 possible function parameters or arguments, module B has six out of the 10. And then they line them all up. And they do it to the extent that there's like 400 character function declarations with like six different contexts. So like, I've been on the bad side of preprocessors. So I'm, you know, good luck, Bryce. Good luck on trying to get me excited about Boost preprocessor.
向我展示这里的魔法吧。好吧。好吧。所以，关于预处理器编程，你首先必须理解的是，圆括号和逗号是特殊的。因为宏本质上总是文本的，如果你有一些东西，你知道的，如果你调用一个宏，比如我有一个名为A的宏，我用类似这样的方式调用它——比如我传入一个模板类型，其中我有不止一个参数，有不止一个模板参数给它，所以类似这样的东西：a，圆括号，x，逗号，y，x，左括号，y，逗号，z，你可能会认为这向宏A传递了一个参数，那个参数将是x，方括号，y，逗号，z，右括号。但实际上这并不是
Show me the magic here. All right. All right. So the first thing that you have to understand about preprocessor programming is that parentheses and commas are special. So because macros are always textual, if you have something, you know, if you call a macro, like if I have a macro called A and I call it with um like i pass in a a template type um where i've got um more than one argument more than one template parameter to it so something like you know a parens x, y, x, open bracket, y, comma, z, you might think that this passes one argument to the macro a, and that argument would be x, brackets, y, comma, z, close brackets. But that's not actually
它的工作原理，因为它是基于文本的。它不认为尖括号具有任何特殊的含义。所以这会向A传递两个参数，而这两个参数将是X小于Y逗号Z大于符号。能跟上我的节奏吗？但是在预处理器中，圆括号是特殊的。它们确实有特殊的含义。因此，如果我采用那个相同的参数并直接用圆括号把它包围起来，那么它就会作为一个参数被传递过去。所以如果我采用那个相同的表达式，我只是用圆括号把它包裹起来，那么它就只会成为宏A的单个参数。于是，这就成了Boost preprocessor支持的所有基于预处理器的数据结构的基础。所以第一个被称为数组（array）。它是，好吧，实际上，
how it works because it's textual. It doesn't recognize the angle brackets as having any special meaning. So this will pass two arguments to A and those arguments will be X less than Y comma Z greater than symbol. Follow me so far? But parentheses are special in the preprocessor. They do have a special meaning. And so if I was to take that same argument and just surround it in parentheses, then it would be passed through as one argument. So if I took that same expression, I just wrapped it in parentheses, then it would be just a single argument to that macro A. And so this becomes the basis of all of the preprocessor-based data structures that Boost preprocessor supports. So the first one is called an array. And it is, well, actually,
我们应该从元组（tuples）开始。你是指元组（tuples）吗？所以一个元组，我们这是要开始了吗？元组？你非要我叫它“元组”，但我不想，我的意思是那是正确的发音，好吧，好吧，元组，好的。所以一个预处理器元组只是一个由圆括号包围的逗号分隔的元素列表。所以就像，你知道的，打印左括号，1，逗号，2，逗号，3，右括号。这是最基础、最简单的预处理器数据结构。它是最有用的数据结构之一，因为它是你会使用的，同时它也是你会用作类似函数的宏的参数的东西，对吧？好吧。好吧。好吧。所以现在我们来谈谈下一个，数组。所以数组是一个两元素的
we should start with tuples. Don't you mean tuples? So a tuple, are we going to do this? Tuples? You want me to call it tuples but i don't i mean that's the correct pronunciation of it okay all right tuples all right so a preprocessor tuple is um uh just a comma separated list of elements that are surrounded by parentheses um so like you know, print opening parentheses, one comma, two comma, three closing parentheses. And this is like the most fundamental and basic preprocessor data structure. And it's one of the more useful ones because it's what you would, it's also what you would use as the argument to a function like macro, right? Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. So now let's talk about the next one, the array. So the array is a two element
元组，其中第一个元素是数组中的元素数量。而第二个元素是数组中实际成员的另一个元组。例如，你知道的，左括号2，逗号，左括号x，逗号，y，右括号右括号，这是一个包含两个元素的数组。第一个是x，第二个是y。我其实从来没有真正经常使用数组这种预处理器数据结构。通常我使用元组或者下一个，序列（sequences）。所以序列只是一组位于圆括号中的东西。就像左括号，1，右括号，左括号，2，右括号，左括号，3，右括号。所以它就像是一组紧挨着彼此的圆括号。这说得通吗？我听懂了。这……你可以说我听懂了，是的。只是为了听众着想，我脑子里现在在想：
tuple where the first element is the number of elements in the array. And the second element is another tuple of the actual members of the array. So for example, you know, open parens 2 comma parens x comma y is an array with two elements. The first is x, and the second is y. I actually never really used the array preprocessor data structure that much. Usually I use tuples or the next one, sequences. So a sequence is just like a group of things that are in parentheses. So like opening parentheses, one, closing parentheses, opening parentheses, two, closing parentheses, opening parentheses, three, closing parentheses. So it's just like a group of like parentheses that are right right next to each other make sense i'm following that's uh you could say that i'm following yes just for the listeners in my head currently i'm going
我很纳闷为什么我们不把这目录在4月1日，或者这会不会是一个终极恶作剧之类的？我只是有点困惑，因为我在想：什么鬼？但你继续。这——我确信你会有所准备的，你是个顶级的营销人员。所以我确信你最终会把这包装得漂漂亮亮，我总会在某个时刻看到它的价值。好吧。好吧。所以接下来我们来谈谈链表（list），这个……其实对你来说应该相当
i'm confused on why we're not recording this on like april 1st or if there's like an omega troll coming like i'm just i'm confused because I'm thinking like, what? But keep going. This is, I'm sure you're going to get to, you're a, you know, a top tier marketer. So I'm sure you're going to have a, you know, you're going to wrap this up with a bow and I'll see some value at some point. All right. All right. So next let's talk about a list and uh this one uh should actually be pretty
熟悉吧？链表，链表，是的，就像Lisp的链表。所以它就像是一个具有头部和尾部的cons风格链表。所以如果你熟悉Lisp中的链表，它的工作方式完全一样。如果我有一个包含三个元素的链表，它的工作方式是：每个，链表总是由两个元素组成的元组，其中第一个元素是链表的头部，第二个元素是包含链表其余部分的另一个链表。所以如果我列出三个元素，它就会像这样：左括号，1，逗号，左括号，2，逗号，左括号，3，逗号。然后你会有这个特殊的终止符，在Boost preprocessor中被称为boost pp nil。然后你会有三个右
you know familiar to you list list yeah it's like a lisp list so it's a it's it's like a a con style list um uh with a head and a tail so um if you're familiar with like lists and lisp, it works just like that. If I had a list of like three elements, the way it would work is each, like the list is always a tuple of two elements where the first element is the head of the list and the second element is another list that contains all the rest of the list. So if I list the three elements, it would be like opening parens, one, comma, opening parens, two, comma, opening parens, three, comma. Then you have this special terminator that in boost preprocessor is called boost pp nil. And then you'd have three closing
括号。所以这是一个你应该会觉得熟悉的数据结构，对吧？是的。我的意思是，依然能跟上。好吧。所以现在你有一些数据结构了。Boost preprocessor库为你提供了各种实用的工具来处理这些数据结构，并做一些事情，比如，你知道的，应用某个宏，将这些数据结构之一的每个元素应用到一个宏上，你知道的，以某种特定方式展开它们，访问特定的元素。然后你就可以开始看到如何进行一些编程了。当然，在这个编程模型中你并没有真正的状态。所以它有点像是一个纯粹的
parens. So this is a data structure that should be familiar to you, right? Yep. I mean, still following. All right. So now you've got some data structures. And the Boost preprocessor library gives you all sorts of useful facilities to working with these data structures and doing things like, you know, apply some macro, apply every element of one of these data structures to some macro, you know, expand them all in a certain way, access certain elements. And so then you can start seeing how you can do some programming. And of course, you don't really have state in this programming model. So it's sort of a purely
函数式编程模型。现在，有一种方法可以让你进行某种有状态的编程。我们稍后会讨论这一点。我敢说，这是最疯狂的事情。但是，你知道，它的理念是，你通过值来传递所有东西，你所做的任何修改都是，你知道的，你在某个东西上做加法，然后你用它调用另一个宏。没有什么可变状态是你可以操作的。好的。那么接下来要谈的，我敢说这是最有用的Boost预处理器函数，是一个叫做——等等，让我在参考文档里找找——叫做expand的函数。许多人的代码库中都有这个函数的某种版本。所以expand的作用是一个类似函数的宏，它接受单个参数，并对其参数进行两次宏展开。所以这在以下情况下很有用：当你想要延迟某个宏的展开，
functional programming model. Now, there is a way that you can do sort of stateful programming. We'll talk about that a little bit later. It's, I'd argue, the craziest thing. But, you know, the idea is that, like, you pass around everything by value and any modifications that you do is, you know, you add to something, then you, you know, call another macro with it. There's no mutable state that you can work with. Okay. So then the next thing to talk about, which I'd argue is the most useful boost preprocessor function, is a function called, hang on, let me go find it in the reference, called expand. And a lot of people's code base have some version of this. So what expand does is it's a function like macro that takes a single argument and it does double macro expansion on its argument. So this is useful when you want to delay expansion of some macro
直到稍后它被重新扫描的时刻。例如，如果你想以编程方式构造对某个宏的调用，比如你，你知道你想调用的宏或函数的名称。但随后你想要构造它的参数，然后将其展开。接着像那样调用那个宏，这就是你使用expand的目的。或者如果你想做一些文本拼接，因为在C++预处理器中你可以做的一件事是，你可以将标记（tokens）粘贴并组合在一起。所以如果我想要基于，你知道的，基本上是将其他一些字符串拼接在一起来分派到一个具有特定名称的宏，你就会使用expand来展开将要使用的那个东西的
until a later time when it's, when it's re-scanned. So for example, if you want to programmatically construct an invocation of some macro, like you, you know, the name of the macro like function that you want to call. But then you want to like construct the arguments to it and then expand it out. And then like, like call that macro, that's what you'd use expand for. Or like if you wanted to do some text pasting, um, cause when it's one of the things you can do in the C++ preprocessor is you can, um, uh, you can paste together tokens. So if I wanted to go in like dispatch to a macro with a certain name um based on like you know basically catting together some other strings um you would use expand to uh uh expand to expand out the name
名称，然后进行调用。所以这是我最经常使用的功能。这大概讲得通吗？这确实讲得通，是的。是的。所以一旦你有了expand和这些数据结构，你就可以开始做很多非常酷的事情了，因为你可以开始，例如，构建，以编程方式构建参数列表，或者以编程方式遍历某些数据。然后你还可以做这种类似REPL的类型。这简直是expand的绝佳类比。Expand就像是REPL。所以expand就像是REPL，或者像我在Python中忘记它叫什么了，也许就像是eval。你知道的，它就像是动态编程语言中的一个函数，
uh of the thing that you're going to go with and then invoke so this is like the most frequent thing that i would use um uh does that kind that kind of make sense? It does make sense, yeah. Yeah. So once you have like expand in these data structures, you can start doing like a lot of really cool stuff because you can start like, for example, building up, programmatically building up lists of arguments or programmatically iterating through some data. And then you can also do this sort of like REPL type. That's the perfect analogy for expand. Expand is like REPL. So expand is like REPL or like, I forget what it's called in Python, like maybe it's like eval. You know, it's like a function in a dynamic programming language
你可以在其中说，嘿，给我这段编程语言的文本，然后我会动态地对其进行求值。等等，暂停。对你来说，REPL是什么意思？对我来说，它意味着“读取-求值-打印-循环”（Read-Eval-Print Loop）。是的。对我的意思也是一样的。
where you say, hey, give me some text of this programming language, and then I'll evaluate it dynamically. Sorry, pause. What does REPL mean to you? For me, it means read eval print loop. Yeah. That's the same meaning for me.
那我就糊涂了。REPL就像是在Python或Haskell中进行开发的一种方式，在那里你只是慢慢地构建表达式，然后执行表达式，接着你就能拿回它的值。对，对。但它就像那种理念……是的，我们说的是同一件事。我在这里只是把它当作一个类比。
I'm confused then. REPL is like a way of developing in Python or Haskell where you are just building up expressions slowly and you execute expressions and then you get the value of it back. Right, right. But it's like that idea in... Yes, we're talking about the same thing. I'm sort of using it as an analogy here.
你经常使用boost pp expand的方式，是你动态地……好吧，在编译时动态地，构建这个你随后想要求值的表达式。这就是boost pp expand的用武之地。这就好像我在构建这个我想要求值的宏表达式。然后我使用boost pp expand来执行该求值。
The way that you often use boost, pp, expand is when you're dynamically... Well, dynamically at compile time, you're building up this expression that you then want to evaluate. That's what boost-pp-expand is useful for. It's like I am building up this macro expression that I want to evaluate. And then I use boost-pp-expand to do that evaluation.
原来如此。这看起来，是的，我觉得它更类似于bash中的eval。对，对。它更类似于bash中的eval之类的东西。我忘了它在Python里叫什么了，但我想可能叫eval。我觉得它在Python里可能也叫eval。是的。是的。但bash中的eval是一个非常好的例子，因为bash和预处理器以及C++预处理器有很多共同点。当然，你还有所有的，你拥有所有C++控制流语句的类似物。所以有boost PP if，它（你知道的）只是一个if条件。它有几种不同的形式。
I see. This seems, yeah, I think it's more similar to like eval in bash. Right, right. It's more similar to something like val and bash. I forget what it's called in Python, but I think maybe it's called eval. I think it might be eval in Python too. Yeah. Yeah. But eval and bash is a really good example because bash and preprocessor and the C++ preprocessor have a lot in common. And of course, you also have all of your, you have the analogs of all of the C++ control flow statements. So there's boost PP if, which is, you know, just an if condition. There's a few different forms of that.
还有boost pp for，它就像一个for循环。然后还有一大堆操作，用于执行各种内置数学运算，并处理诸如布尔值、整数之类的主流数据类型。因为在任何类型的编程框架中，你当然也需要这些。现在请记住，在类似于预处理器的pound if中，
There is boostpp4, which is just like a for loop. And then there's a whole bunch of operations for doing all of the various built-in math and working with built-in data types like bools and ints and whatnot. Because of course you need that too in any sort of programming framework. Now keep in mind in something like a preprocessor pound if,
你可以只使用常规的C++风格操作。如果你这样做，你知道的，pound if，a小于零，这样就能直接起作用。但如果你只是在宏求值中，你知道的，那就不起作用了。在宏求值中，如果你有A小于零，那不会进行特殊求值，因为宏求值纯粹是在处理文本。所以如果你想做类似小于号这样的事情，你需要为此用到一些特殊的魔法。现在，康纳，我要向你展示其中一些东西是什么样的。我们要看看你觉得它有多可怕。所以我要向你展示
you can just use regular C++ style operations. Like if you do, you know, pound if, you know, a less than, you know, zero, like that'll just work. But if you're just in the macro evaluation, you know, that won't work. In a macro evaluation, if you have A less than zero, that's not going to evaluate special because the macro evaluation is just purely working with text. So if you want to do something like less than, you need some special magic for that. And now, Connor, I'm going to show you what some of these things look like. And we're going to see how terrifying you find it. So I'm going to show you
自增函数。这就是自增函数的样子。哦，天哪。这个文件有多少行？好吧，所以这个支持对最多256个数据类型进行自增。因此，Boost预处理器库中的许多操作仅适用于最多256个左右的东西。你可能会好奇为什么。这似乎是个奇怪的限制。我会解释，而且我也会解释为什么康纳刚刚笑了。
the increment function. This is what the increment function looks like. Oh, goodness. How many lines is this file? Well, so this one supports incrementing up to 256 data types. So a lot of the operations in the Boost preprocessor library will only work for up to like 256 of something. And you might wonder why. That's like a weird limit. And I'll explain and I'll also explain why Connor just laughed.
所以Boost.pp.inc是一个获取某个值并给它加1的函数。以下是它的实现方式：有256个宏，分别叫做boost、pp、inc、impl、tag、in。所以有tag 0、tag 1、tag 2、tag 3、tag 4、tag 5、tag 6，一直到256。对于tag 0，该值展开为1。对于tag 1，该值展开为2。对于tag 2，该值展开为3，以此类推，直到最后一个。所以Boost.ppinc宏所做的事情是，它获取你给它的作为数字的参数，并将该数字拼接到字符串“thrust pp inc impl tag”上。所以如果我用5来调用它，它所做的是获取那个5，并把它拼接到字符串
So Boost.pp.inc is a function that takes some value and it adds one to it. And here's how it does it. There are 256 macros that are called boost, pp, inc, impl, tag, in. So there's like tag zero, tag one, tag two, tag three, tag four, tag five, tag six, all the way up to 256. And for tag 0, the value expands to 1. For tag 1, the value expands to 2. For tag 2, the value expands to 3, etc., up to the last one. And so then what the Boost.ppinc macro does is it takes the argument that you gave it, which is a number, and it pastes that number to the string thrust pp inc impl tag. So if I call it with, you know, five, what it does is it takes that five and it pastes it to the end of a string
“thrust PP ink impl tag”的末尾，然后展开那个宏。因此，这会去分派到名为，你知道的，下划线tag 5的宏，而那个宏的值是6。所以那个宏展开的结果就是6，这正是你对5加1进行自增所期望的结果。这就是Boost Preprocessor中所有基本数学和逻辑运算的工作原理。康纳，我给你展示一个更有趣的，也就是，我们正在滚动的减速，但好吧。所以这里是bool，thrust PP bool。这应该是一个布尔数据类型，有点像，你知道的，C++的bool，你给它某个值，它返回1或0。它的工作原理是一样的。
thrust PP ink impl tag, and then it expands that macro. And so that would go and dispatch to the macro that's called, you know, underbar tag five, and the value of that macro is 6. So then the result of that macro expansion is 6, which is the result that you would expect if you incremented 5 by 1. This is how all of the basic math and logic operations work in Boost Preprocessor. I'll show you the funnier one, Connor, which is, so there's decrement that we're scrolling through, but okay. So here's bool, thrust PP bool. And this is, it's supposed to be a bool data type, just sort of like, you know, C++'s bool, where you give it some, you know, value and it returns either 1 or 0. And it does the same thing.
只是对于bool的情况，tag值为0时，值为0。而对于其他所有255个tag，值都是1。难道没有更好的方法来做到这一点吗？没有更好的方法来做到这一点。没有更好的方法来做到这一点，没有更好的方法来做到这一点，因为你没有任何……你没有任何基本操作。在宏求值中，你基本上可以做到……你拥有的唯一真正的基本操作就是文本拼接。所以，我提到过好几次，有双哈希运算符。因此，如果在某个类似函数的宏中使用A双哈希B，
Just in the case of bool, the tag values are for tag 0, the value is 0. And for all 255 other tags, the value is 1. There's no better way to do that? There is no better way to do this. There is no better way to do that there is no better way to do this there is no better way to do this because you don't have any you don't have any basic operations like the the in macro evaluation you basically can do like the only real primitive operation that you have is text pacing. So there's the, I mentioned this a few times, there's the double hash operator. So if you do A double hash B within some function like macro,
那会将A的展开与B的展开拼接在一起。你拥有这个，而且你拥有进行延迟展开的能力，仅此而已。因此，如果你想构建任何更复杂的运算，你必须基于将字符串连接在一起然后展开它们来构建它们。所以每个操作都必须像这样基于表（table-based）来实现。但这实际上引出了我认为我最喜欢的宏技巧。这是我最常使用的技巧。而且我认为，这只是那些比较自然且平易近人的事情之一，你不需要做任何异想天开的事情——就像我会用预处理器做的那样——就能欣赏到这一点。这就是可变参数（variadic），或者说不是可变参数，而是，我称之为
that will paste the expansion of A to the expansion of B. You have that and you have the ability to do like delayed expansion and that's it. So if you want to build up any more complex operations, you have to build them up based on concatenating together strings, and then expanding them out. So every operation has to be implemented table-based like this. But this actually gets to what I think is my favorite macro trick. And it's the one that like I use most frequently. And it's the thing that I think is, it's just one of the more natural and approachable things that you don't have to be doing anything, anything sort of out there like I would do with the preprocessor to appreciate this. And it is this pattern for variadic, or not variadic, for, well, I call it
宏重载的模式。这是一种可变参数宏的风格，你可以这样编写一个宏：如果它接受一个参数，就有一种实现；如果它接受两个参数，就有另一种实现；如果它接受三个参数，又有一种实现，等等。所以这有点像重载。这里我向你展示这种模式是什么样子的。所以这个理念是，比方说我想拥有某个名为——这里的例子是plus——的宏，我想让它支持接受任意数量的东西然后将它们加在一起。这个神奇的东西，在我们的库中我们称之为thrust PP dispatch，你可以做的是编写你的主函数，你的接口名称，在本例中是plus，并且plus将是一个可变参数宏。但它实际上不会包含任何实现逻辑。
macro overloading. And it's a style of variadic macro where you can write a macro in a way where you can have one implementation if it takes, you know, one argument, one implementation if it takes two arguments, one implementation if it takes three arguments, etc. So it's sort of like overloading. So here I'm showing you what the pattern looks like. So the idea is like, let's say that I wanted to have some macro called, well, the example here is plus, where I wanted it to support taking an arbitrary number of things and then like adding it together. this magic thing that in our library we call thrust PP dispatch, what you can do is you write your main function, the name of your interface, in this case plus, and plus is going to be a variadic macro. But it's not going to actually contain any of the implementation logic.
它只会包含对thrust PP dispatch的调用。而那个调用，它将把名称的第一部分作为它的第一个参数。所以通常你把它设为函数本身的名称。然后它将获取所有的可变参数。接着你编写一系列实现函数。所以我编写了一个名为plus的函数，或者一个名为plus零、接受零个参数的宏，一个名为plus一、接受一个参数的宏，一个名为plus二、接受两个参数的宏，
It's just going to have this call to thrust PP dispatch. And that call, it'll take as its first argument, the first part of a name. So usually you make it the name of the function itself. And then it'll take all the variadic arguments. And then you write a series of implementation functions. So I write a function called like plus, or a macro called plus zero that takes zero arguments, a macro called plus one that takes one argument, a macro called plus two that takes two arguments,
一个名为plus三、接受两个参数的宏，一个名为plus三、接受三个参数的宏。并且当调用thrust PP dispatch时，它会计算调用它时传入的参数数量、你传递的可变参数的数量。然后它会将那个数字拼接到你作为第一个参数给它的名称上。接着它会带上这些参数调用拼接在一起的名称。所以如果我用两个参数调用plus这个可变参数宏，它就会带上两个参数调用plus二。因此，我发现这是一种用于处理可变参数的极其有用的模式，因为你在这里可以非常容易地实现诸如可选参数之类的事情。没错。如果我想拥有一个最多可以接受三个参数的宏，并且最后一个参数总可以是可选的。用这个方法来做非常简单轻松，而且我可以在同一个名称下完成所有这些。
a macro called plus three that takes two arguments, a macro called plus three that takes three arguments. And thrust PP dispatch will, when you call it, it'll count the number of arguments that it was called with, the number of variadic arguments that you passed in. And then it will paste that number to the name that you gave it as your first argument. And then it will invoke the concatenated together name with those arguments. So if I call plus my variadic macro with two arguments, it will call plus two with two arguments. So I find this to be an incredibly useful pattern for working with variadic arguments because you can do things like optional parameters very easily here. Right. That if I want to have a macro that can take, you know, up to three arguments and the last argument can always be optional. It's very easy and simple to do with this and I can do it all under one name.
这真的是其中最棒的部分，就像在C++中一样，我可以在同一个名称下拥有一组重载。哦，天哪，我的头好痛。我们的第一部分对话就到这里结束。请收听下周播出的第二部分：“万能宏”。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。
And that's really the nice part of this is that just like in C++ I can have sort of like an overload set under the same name oh man my head hurts that's where we'll end part one of this conversation tune in next week for part two of macros almighty There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这其实是这东西很棒的一面，就像在 C++ 里一样，我可以在同一个名字下拥有一组重载。天哪，我的头好痛，我们对话的第一部分就到这里结束。请收听下周的宏全能第二部分。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。